bonjour verrait alors comment la russie
a réagi à ces accusations
bonjour amira la russie n'avait n'a et
n'aura jamais aucune volonté de
politiser le sujet des vaccins ni
d'utiliser le vaccin en tant qu'outil d'
influence affirmé le porte parole du
président russe dmitri peskov
pour lui cette déclaration du manuel
macron relève de profondes divergences
entre la russie et la france je vous
propose d'écouter première chose nous
apprécions beaucoup le dialogue de
confiance entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine ainsi que la volonté et
le souhait du président macron
d'examiner les questions les plus
complexes dans le cadre de ce dialogue
deuxième chose les présidents ont
effectivement des échanges très efficace
sans éviter les questions les plus
épineuses
il y à toute une gamme de questions au
sujet desquels ils sont en désaccord
profond
ce qui ne les empêche pas de poursuivre
leurs échanges ces déclarations de
monsieur macron relève probablement de
nos profondes divergences
nous rejetons catégoriquement
l'allégation selon laquelle la russie et
la chine mène une sorte de guerre civile
et d'autres couteau les concepteurs du
vaccin spoutnik v ont également réagi
aux accusations d' emmanuel macron ils
ont publié un tweet en faveur d'un
apaisement est tout en soulignant
l'importance de la coopération et coûter
cher emmanuel macron rendre les vaccins
à politique est notre meilleur espoir de
paix mondiale et non de guerre
nous apprécions l'envoi d'une équipe
scientifique française sous la direction
de marie paule kieny
et notre partenariat avec la france qui
nous a beaucoup aidés et a contribué à
notre combat commun contre locaux vides
la russie a proposé à la france de
rejoindre les 10 autres pays qui ont
accepté de produire spoutnik v la
production de différents vaccins est une
véritable voie vers l'indépendance
vaccinale ensemble nous sommes plus
forts
je rappelle que le vaccin russe foot ni
clé est enregistrée
actuellement dans une cinquantaine de
pays du monde entier il fait partie de
trois vaccins élaborés en russie merci à
vera pour toutes ces précisions